the way we found out about this is well
people were suspicious for a long time
like I said in 2007 to Microsoft
researchers already pointed out that if
somebody had known a relation between
these two solutions then they would be
able to crack the algorithm but we
couldn't know for sure
so I think some red flags were raised
and people were concerned but we didn't
know whether you know this was happening
or not but in September the Guardian and
the New York Times published reports in
which they relying on the information
provided by Snowden they confirmed that
indeed that's what happened in some ways
it seems that the NSA was aware of the
relation between the two and that was
one of the tools instead of their
arsenal in terms of arsenal of you know
being able to eavesdrop into and to
decrypt what people believed was
encrypted safely encrypted information
however I think that if once people are
aware of this and they start actively
searching for that relation they may be
able to find it and that's what I think
poses the greatest danger here that once
you create sort of a backdoor it's
almost like you have a door but you make
a little hole to let your dog in I
didn't say okay lonely the dog will be
able to get in but nobody else but then
next thing you know the cats going
coming in that you know the mom is
coming in and all kinds of other animals
how do you prevent that and and also the
problem is if you don't tell anyone that
people think that's both proof the door
is bulletproof and nobody can carry on
and then turns out that there is
actually a hole so that creates a
problem and that's an issue so what we
have here is very sophisticated
mathematics being used for encryption
and the problem is that mathematics can
be used for good but also for ill and
MIT can be misused and these four modes
are powerful and they can help us in our
daily lives they can simplify things
they can make things they can encrypt
things and so on but there is also
opportunity to for misuse and I think
that more people should be aware of how
these things are done
what exactly goes in and I think that if
we are more aware of this maybe we will
be able to have some safeguards and to
prevent these formulas this mathematical
equations from being misused one last
thing I know you're just a lowly
mathematician and I'm just a lowly guy
with a camera but this seems
extraordinary that companies were using
this so that something they'll being
spoon-fed by the government almost
without question that makes them seem
stupid that they used it well I guess
there is a lot of sort of a finger
pointing and second-guessing going on
right now
we were there were reports that some
companies which were using this
algorithms actually advise their clients
to stop using them so that was a huge
embarrassment for them I imagine and I
think this revelations they kind of
makes make us question the whole set up
now because there were certain things
that people took for granted and now we
are we have to reevaluate this and maybe
also we have to create some mathematics
which would be such that no one would be
able to misuse it in such as in such a
sort of obvious way I'm so be kind of a
kind of mathematics which is just set up
in such a way that even if you wanted to
use it it wouldn't be possible and I
think now maybe we should work more in
this direction I know this is serious
and a lot of people who are very upset
about what happened but on a purely just
entertainment level isn't this cool that
mathematics is being used in this kind
of James Bond style got away no I agree
because you know people always ask me
your mathematician so what do you do
like how is it relevant to the real
world well now I can just point them to
this and said look US government talks
about elliptic curves the National
Security Agency was using elliptic
curves so this are not it's attic
objects anymore this is something that
you use in your daily life and so that's
very interesting and I think that if
anyone is not come if there's anyone
who's not convinced that Mad Max is
playing a larger and larger role in this
war in this brave new world I think they
should be convinced now